baby aiders are safe and stylish
sunglasses for babies and young kids
they're made out of rubber so they bend
and twist and straighten and return to
their natural shape we came up with the
idea for baby aiders in South Carolina
my husband is an aviator for the United
States Marine Corps we were out on the
runway watching the pilots fly and I
noticed all the adults had sunglasses on
and the kids were actually squinting in
the Sun trying to see their moms and
their dads and the planes of air we
launched baby aters with my partner
Carolyn and myself sitting in our
respective kitchen tables literally cold
calling Children's Boutique we surveyed
our friends who are parents their
biggest complaint about sunglasses on
the market is that they get lost so we
started toying around with this
irrational offer of let's just replace
them if they get lost so that's how he
came up with the lobster conch guarantee
and we were the only sight loss is
friend in the world that we know of that
does this I get a lot of reactions like
how do you stay in business that is a
profitable in the three years of selling
baby eight or sunglasses we've gone from
1 million to 2 million to a projected 4
million dollars in sales you do have
those people that seek out their free
pair but those are the the most
enthusiastic brand ambassadors so yeah
she gave a free pair but then you might
have sold 4 or 5 more because of that
one prepare about a year into working on
baby eaters we had our son Sawyer that
first winner we had him I literally lost
seven different winter hats my partners
and I all realized then that we wanted
to expand into different products why
not make it happy you can guarantee
against loss why not make swimming
goggles all these things get lost and
should be replaced for free so that's
what we're doing